the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
well so three things to mention one was
you remember last time I made a list of
six or seven different situations where
they X equal B and problems that could
arise the last one was when a was just
way too big to fit into core but in the
middle were other methods so other
issues like columns being nearly
dependent when gram-schmidt will come up
first I want to say that I know there
are typos in the two pages I I thought
you might just like to see the very
first draft of two pages of the book so
people sometimes ask me how long does
the book take to write so I started when
1806 five started a year ago so I'm into
the second year and it usually takes two
years and the system is I write by hand
so I wrote those opening pages that you
saw two pages by hand then I scan them
to Mumbai where my best friend in the
world
types them with typos no problem because
I'm gonna make so many changes that a
few typos are nothing anyway so he scans
them back to me typed and then I start
making changes if I'm lucky and have the
chance to talk about it in here then I
realize better things to do and I scan
back to him and back to me and back to
him and back to me so that's where that
two years disappear anyway I'm quite
happy with those two pages until I start
improving them okay and one other topic
from the past that I thought was that
came out in class wasn't in the notes
yet do you remember the day that we
minimized
different norm
l1 or l2 or max L infinity norm for with
the condition of solving with a
constraint that this equation was
satisfied I'm in 2d to be able to draw a
picture and the constraint is one line
and that's about what the line looks
like so I'm gonna draw here again so
what I'm doing is putting some numbers
in to that insight that I drew about a
week ago do you remember that because I
thought that really illustrates why how
L 1 and L 2 and L infinity are different
let's let me draw the L 2 1 here so
where's the point on this line so the X
has to lie on this line and where is the
point that has the smallest sum of
squares norm standard L 2 norm so
geometrically where is that point well
what does the set of points with norm
one look like for L 2 it's a circle
right so we just blow that circle up or
shrink it down until it touches this
thing and now it'll touch where it
touches it'll touch where our radius is
perpendicular so there's the circle
there's our best point in L 2 because if
because if we picked another point we'd
have to blow the norm that norm would
have to be bigger to go through that
point so that's clearly the first one
and and actually we can probably see
what it is because those if we know
those are perpendicular I know the slope
of this line so I think that the slope
of this line is something like 3/4
probably coming from there or maybe 4/3
I can we'll figure it out I think it's
four thirds yeah I think that I'll find
that point then the most interesting one
was the l1 norm because what was the
shape of the unit ball for l1 a diamond
right a diamond so the diamond that
first touches the line is here that's
the winning point and if the line is 3 X
1 plus 4 X 2 equal 1 then I know that
that point is X X 1 will be 0 and X 2
will be 1/4 so that's the winning point
in l1 and I think I calculated this
right that's a winning point in l2
I think will be let's see this goes up
to I I'm so moving down the line I think
this would have three twenty fifths for
twenty fifths I won't stop to derive
that but at least now this yeah that
slope is looking like 4/3 goes up for
when it crosses three and that four and
the three came from there and of course
you notice I've chosen that I've scaled
it to fit the line three times three
fifths in 3 2015 9 25th
Plus 16 25th 25th is 1 and finally what
about L infinity what was the picture
there what's the unit ball look like in
2d for the max norm it's a square right
so the square will hit there these two
on the square are this is a 45-degree
line now on that square it hits it at
that sharp point and so the x1 and the
x2 are equal and I think they're
probably
let's see if they're equal if me if we
made them 1/7 that would be
then I have three sevenths plus four
sevens equals 7/7 yeah I think we make
some one seventh one seventh then so
that would be the X infinity point 3/7
plus 4/7 gives one so why do I mention
this first because when I did it before
I just threw pictures without really
solving the problem and secondly because
in thinking of ahead about projects this
is the kind of project that I would
think is quite interesting obviously as
this is P equal 1 this is P equal to
this is P equal infinity and I guess
it's pretty clear from the pictures that
as P increases this point starts up here
and moves down the line and ends up here
and I have no idea like what to move
what the solution is for a different P
and how it moves and to make it make it
more about project what happens in 3d
what happens in 3d in 3d if I have one
equation in 3d then I have a plane and
these this would become a diamond a 3d
diamond this would be a 3d sphere this
would be a 3d cube they would expand to
hit that plane and I don't know how many
zeroes you get in that case so that
would be the case of one one equation so
there'd be a plane that these diamond
Q's sphere and Q expand until they hit
it or you could have two constraints two
equations so if we had two equations and
three unknowns that would be a line
again but would we get how many zeroes
would we get in these different cases
how sparse is l1 gonna be okay can I
just that's like a recapture of what we
did I thought it was a it's nice
occasionally
have pictures showing what what a
solution where the solution is now I'm
coming to the to the topic of the day
which is gram-schmidt and so
gram-schmidt number one is the standard
way that would be taught in 1806 and the
result is so what's gram-schmidt about
and I'll just put down here general
facts of gram-schmidt we start with a
matrix a it's got n columns but they're
not orthogonal and in fact they may be
badly conditioned columns might be
nearly dependent on the others I'm gonna
assume the columns are independent but
they might be barely independent so
gram-schmidt so they're those lines then
would be sort of like pointing very
nearly parallel but gram-schmidt opens
up the picture to get a matrix q an
orthogonal matrix with columns Q 1 to Q
n which are orthonormal so it gets a
perfect basis of Q's and so that's what
gram-schmidt does and these are
different ways to do it different ways
to organize the computation I really
only put the standard way in what is
this mysterious R I claim that so they
come these these the Q's are
combinations of the A's so there's some
matrix to tell me what those
combinations are or if I go back go
backwards and say well the A's are
combinations of the Q's that's what I'm
about to do if I say each a is a
combination of Q's that means that my a
may
Trix is my Q matrix time some are matrix
which tells me the combinations right
when I multiply by R on the right I'm
taking combinations of the columns of Q
and getting the columns of a so just
like Lu it's kind of you go forward with
the algorithm to reach you here we go
forward with the algorithm to reach Q
but then when we want to understand put
it put it in one simple equation it
turns out to be like better to go
backwards and say how is the original a
related to the final Q and there has to
be some R ok I always feel when I talk
about gram-schmidt I usually end with
that equal Q R and of course the MATLAB
command is exactly Q R so in MATLAB
you're asking for the command would be Q
R of a instead of Lu of a so it would
give you a Q and R that's what MATLAB
will output now as I say Q is the thing
we're constructing R is the combinations
that we need to get what we want and so
it's a little it comes at the end
what the heck was R but actually R is
really a simple idea so I want to show
that at the beginning instead of the end
okay so I'm going to move Q over here as
Q inverse but what is Q inverse Q
transpose right because I've created an
orthogonal matrix so this mysterious R
is Q transpose a and let me just put
here the let me sort of make it grow out
into matrices that has the Q's along the
rows Q transpose of course QN transpose
Q 1 transpose I just
I'm transposing the matrix above it so
these columns become rows times the A's
a 1 to a n so what is a typical entry in
our that's really why I want to say
nothing mysterious about this you can
see what you end up with it'll be right
in front of us here what is a typical
what is the entry in row I column J of
our ok this this says that all those
entries in our our Qi transpose times AJ
right that's the old way to multiply
matrices and on it's the best way for
this a row times a column in other words
the ours are just the inner product the
dot product of the Q's with the 8th of
the Q's with the A's that's that's sort
of like nothing mysterious about our
because Q is an orthogonal matrix we
were able to put it over here
get a nice expression for R and see what
it really is so are you good you can do
are at the end or on the route but it's
just the inner product of the Q's with
the A's ok now what's gram-schmidt can I
I'm sort of thinking you've seen the
basic ideas of gram-schmidt but let's
review so I start with I start with a so
what does gram-schmidt begin with a 1 it
takes that first column so so these a z'
are not orthogonal generally but the
first direction is okay
I have no complaints about the first
direction except that a one might not be
a unit vector so q1 will just be a one
over its norm to have a unit vector the
whole idea of gram-schmidt is in q2 so
what is q2 the whole idea is coming here
yeah it's the only thing you need to
know and the picture shows it so q2 I
start with a - but it's not orthogonal
to a-1
so what do I do I figure out the
component of a queue of a2 in the a one
direction and I remove it so I take that
vector away and I'm left with this
vector so there is a vector I'll call
that a 2 so a2 is the original little a2
with the a One Direction removed so a2
is like so what what's the formula for
what I just did this is the hole the key
step that that gram-schmidt repeats over
and over and over again it's truly
boring
okay so it subtracts well remember that
this is the same direction as q1 and
it's better to work with q1 because
we've found that guy we've got it and we
know we know it's a unit vector so
here's my linear algebra question what's
the component of a 2 that I want to
subtract off its the component in the
direction of Q 1 it's this in the
direction of Q 1 and let me just
remember
so obviously that angle is coming into
it so that'll be an a 2 transpose Q 1
times Q 1 that's it
that's the component that we removed
maybe I maybe I'd prefer to write it as
q1 transpose a - I don't know
doesn't matter of course the tube dot
products are there saying maybe I will
just yeah yeah well okay now what is
supposed to what does what does that
vector supposed to achieve it's supposed
to be this vector this is this vector
I'm really going to call a two because
it's on in the right direction for q2
but it is not yet normal so what is q2
then so I'm saying this guy got the
direction right this thing subtracted
off this vector got that direction right
it got it as a - what is q2 now that I
want to finish I've got the direction
all I want to do is get it to be a unit
vector so I just take a 2 over its
normal that double step is the whole
thing in gram-schmidt the whole thing
subtract off the components in the
directions already set and you get
something in a totally new direction
called a capital A and then you divide
by its length to make it a unit vector
and that gives you the new Q so you see
just to show that we've got the point
what about the next step aiming for q3
so tell me what a 3 should be a 3 I'm
gonna start with this and I'm going to
subtract off some stuff what am I going
to subtract off
is the component III transpose right x
q1 q1 and I didn't yet check that that
makes that this came out orthogonal to
q1 I'll come back to that now I have I
have I done everything I should do here
with a three no I've got one more step
to take and I should take the two steps
separately
it's called modified gram-schmidt and
what I want to do is subtract off the q2
component so what what multiple of q2 do
I need to because q2 has been set by the
time I get to a3 so what what goes here
a3 transpose Q 2 thanks thanks you if
you look at a code say a MATLAB code to
do gram-schmidt Oh what's the final q3
then normalize it so you take a 3 which
is in the right direction and you divide
by its length to get a unit vector yeah
let me just come back and write and
recheck that I did it right that I got
the right direction so what do I mean by
the right direction what should I have
what should I check about that guy I
should check that its inner product with
q1 is it if this is the right direction
to go that way then I should check I
have to check hopefully I got the
formula right that it's dot product
inner product with Q 1 is 0
thank you so let me just so is it
obvious that it is take the inner
product of the dot product of that with
q1 what do you get you get
you get the same number Q 1 a 2
transpose Q 1 you get that number and
over here you're getting a Q 1 transpose
Q 1 transpose with Q 1 so I'm you see
what I'm doing and Bobby it looks like
it would have been better I check that Q
1 transpose a 2 is 0 yeah it is Q 1
transpose a 2 here Q 1 transpose a 2 or
a 2 transpose Q 1 I don't mind and I
have another Q 1 transpose Q 1 here and
what is that what is Q 1 transpose Q 1
it is 1 so check
okay that's gram-schmidt standard Ram
Smit which you have met before now I'm
ready for a better gram-schmidt you
could say I'm better gram-schmidt
because here so what's it going to be
the difference here I took the A's in
their original order now suppose I did
that with elimination elimination
usually we write as acting on the row so
so thinking of elimination I'm seeing in
the rows what would be the danger in
taking the rows in order doing no row
exchanges just figure out the pivot each
time and kill the rest of the column and
then move on so taking the rows in the
order they came whatever it might be
what's the risk and what why would
MATLAB not do that because something can
be very small and totally blow up your
calculation and that's that pivot number
sort of the question is you know if a2
is very near a one so let me draw a new
picture so here's the risk so a1 was
whatever it was if a 2 is really close
to the same direction then I'm
subtracting off almost all of it and
I've got some tiny little bit for the
new direction that's like the pivot in
elimination it's the number that sort of
measures what's new what's a new row and
elimination or the new column in
gram-schmidt gives you and if that's too
small I mean like in elimination we
would as I say we would never use an
elimination code on a general matrix
that didn't check the size of the pivot
and exchange rows when necessary well
similarly with gram-schmidt it can take
those columns in order that's the
standard gram-schmidt taking the columns
in order but only if it checks each time
that a little bit that a little bit well
that the in the new part what would be
the new part is is big enough to be able
to we have to divide by the thing and if
that a2 is tiny is a tiny vector this is
dividing by a 2 and and onwards is
building in roundoff error that we can't
remove again it's we're stuck with it so
that's the column exchange column
pivoting idea in a sort of a more
professional gram-schmidt and it needs
to do it so i have to be able to check
compare this this little bit if it is
little with what what am I going to
compare with in elimination I looked
down the rest of the column for a bigger
number here I want to know I guess what
I have to do is I have to find this this
component not just from a2 but from all
the remaining A's and I'll pick the
biggest so there in in that sentence I
said the main idea of column exchanges
is once you get q1 set which was
certainly q1 was the easiest one in the
world but maybe even for q1 oh I guess
it could even happen
you like that would be starting like
starting with a0 up in the upper left
corner for elimination like like what a
way to start the day here if a1 if my
matrix a had a tiny little a1 then I
should look for a bigger one to get the
very first Q chosen let's suppose give
ourselves a reasonable chance here let's
suppose a one was a decent size so so as
I've drawn then but a 2 might not or the
next step might not be if I use a 2 as I
say it could be same direction as a1
virtually and then I'm just working with
that little piece so what's the what do
I have to do differently I have to be
able to compare this little piece with
all the other potential possibilities so
so let me just write down what you have
to do you have to do in a different
order so this is now with column
pivoting column exchange column pivoting
allowed or as possible
so to make it possible I have to find
not only a to the piece of Q of little a
- I have to find a to the piece I'm just
gonna copy that I have to take my second
column subtract off the q1 part and that
could be small so I have to compare it
with
oh I haven't I haven't written this page
up so I haven't got a notation in mind
yet
let me I won't I won't give it a name I
have to also compute at this step before
deciding before deciding q2 this is non
describing how do how to decide q2 the
second vector and I'm saying that the
way to decide q2 is not only to look not
only to take the piece of a2 but also
the piece of a3 look at this piece and
look at all the other pieces
and now what will be my policy standard
gram-schmidt accepted this one and
didn't look at these but now I'm gonna
look at them all and I'm gonna take the
largest I'm gonna take the largest and
that will be a 2 thought I want so it
might not be this one if this guy is
largest then I'm taking column 3 first
and that will be my a2 and then I'll say
fine and then Q 2 will be this that a2
over its normal you see the difference
it's not exciting and you might think
wait a minute this is a heck of a lot
more work but it isn't it isn't actually
more work because these are all the
things these ones that look like we're
paying a price we're computing all these
alternatives but we had to do that
eventually anyway do you see that let me
say it again and and that the standard
way took all the components like for
here a standard way waited until you got
to column 3 and then subtract it off
both pieces waited until you got to
column 4 subtracted off three pieces
this way you're subtracting off the
first piece as soon as you know what it
should be as soon as you know q1 you
remove it from all the remaining vectors
and you look to sees what's the biggest
you pick the biggest one I said maybe
it's this guy so you move that one
you're some permutation matrix is going
to move it to the second column see it
started in the third column but I'm
gonna move it to the second because it's
the biggest then I do the right thing I
find q2 and now I go on
- sir
the third acute or toward q3 and how
will I find q3 it'll be I'll say olive I
want to pick the biggest column to work
with so I subtract off the q2 components
this is like easy to say but I had never
liked figured it out before so let me
just say it again and then I'll leave
that with you how do I get q3 I've got
I've fixed two columns they happen to be
maybe not necessarily the first two but
two columns two queues are set and I'm
looking for the next one okay I go on
and I look at all the remaining columns
all of which have had subtracted off
their q1 and q2 parts
so I've orthogonalize with respect to q1
and q2 I look at all the remaining
things that I have to work with and pick
the biggest just like picking the
biggest number to go into the pivot okay
that's that's I don't think I can say it
any more without just repeating myself
and I bring it here into class because I
had not sort of appreciated the point
that that no extra work was involved you
just did these subtraction off
subtractions for all the remaining
columns of a before you start on the
next job is that okay
eventually the notes will describe that
maybe they even do yeah I think they
even do I wrote it but I didn't
understand it now
little improvement okay so yes yeah yeah
only we don't call them pivots or we
should maybe we should I don't know what
word is used to get the biggest column
remaining
or something yeah yeah yeah each time
right it's just you know if the columns
were in a stupid order this puts them in
the right order okay finally come these
weird names cried off Russian are no the
actually I don't know what he isn't I
shouldn't admit that on the tape so
what's the what's the idea there so
again we're solving ax equal B so this
is gonna be cried off what's what was
his idea well I want to solve ax equal B
a is a big matrix pretty big of course I
don't plan to invert it that would be
insane what I can do with a big matrix a
especially if it's sparse which made it
so that that would be a large sparse a
would be a good would be a good
candidate for Krylov so what is it that
you can do cheap and fast with a large I
mean really large but really sparse
matrix a you can do a matrix times a
vector and here's our matrix and there's
our vector so or yeah we could start
with a vector B we can multiply a times
B we can multiply a times a times B and
of course I write it that way I never I
never I mean like if you multiply a a
times a first then like you know
turn in your MATLAB account you just
have to do it that way
okay and then you keep going which of
course that's a squared B but you didn't
form a squared and then on up to in the
end you get to some a to the say K K
minus one
be but of course that's computed as a
times the previous one which was eight
times the previous one so there is a
bunch of vectors which are likely to be
independent that so they span a space
and it's called the Krylov space so
there's these span they're combinations
combinations
give-give
oh I don't like that letter K cuz that's
also Krylov so what shall I say J so I
have J vector z' the original B a B a
squared B up to that so combinations
give the Krylov space say it will name
it after crying off and we need we need
a subscript J to show how big it is it's
dimension so so that will be the idea
well let me complete the idea the idea
will be so there combination so that's a
space a subspace pretty big if we do if
J is big and I'm going to look for the
best solution in that space so I'm going
to I'm not going to solve ax equal B
exactly I'm gonna find the best solution
the closest solution the least square
solution in this Krylov space I'm gonna
let J be pretty big so this space has
got plenty of vectors in it I have a
basis for this space what I and some
combination of these basis vectors will
be my X J so I again XJ will be the best
vector or the closest vector the closest
vector in this Krylov space KJ the bet
will be the best vector in that space
the closest one so I know what the space
is I've reduced the dimension down to J
and I can find this best factor there's
just one catch and it's the same catch
that gram-schmidt we're aiming to help
to to remove that is this basis that I'm
right now I'm working with all
combinations of these guys and those
could be very very dependent that might
be a terrible basis anytime you wanted
to
big computations what kind of a basis do
you want yes so what sort of a basis is
good to find to project on to to find
the best solution within that subspace
so you're sort of finding a projection
and you've got you've got vectors that
span the space so you know what you're
projecting on to but those vectors might
not be they might be nearly dependent
they might all be pointing almost the
same direction in which case your
calculations are terrible so what do you
do orthe orthogonalize right and that's
where our nolde comes in and there's
also a Hungarian guy named LAN shows so
that's what they contribute is how to
orthogonalize that basis and then once
you've done that you
have an orthogonal basis and of course
an orthogonal basis is perfect to do a
projection do you see everybody has to
know that why is an orthogonal basis so
great orthonormal even let's just
remember suppose I have a vector X it's
unknown here but suppose I suppose I
have it and I want to write it as our
combination of these orthonormal guys so
you say yeah what is it about
orthonormal Q's that makes this easy to
do which it would not be with a
arbitrary basis so this this is really
cute I'm see right Q times this vector
of C's column the Q the Q's are in the
columns of Q the C's we're multiplying a
matrix by a vector that's just okay it's
a combination of the columns that's what
we get and what's the point of when
these when the Q's are orthogonal
what's the answer we can get the answer
straight away so we here we're trying to
we're trying to find the coefficients
with respect to the basis vectors Q of a
given vector X and what's the answer to
that question the point is usually to
find their coefficients C would have to
be Q inverse X we'd have to solve that
system of equations we do have to solve
that system of equations but what
where's the payoff from or thought
whoreson normal basis q inverse is Q
transpose that's the payoff so it's
telling me
that to find c1 how do I find c1 this
this says take the first q1 transpose
with X that I'll say the same thing here
take the first component the first
vector with X that'll be about c1 Q 1
transpose Q 1 I'm just taking the dot
product of everything there with Q 1 and
then a C 2 Q 1 transpose Q 2 and so on
but what's good it tell me again the
these are all 0 and the Q 1 transpose Q
1 is 1 so it's perfect C 1 is Q 1
transpose X and that's exactly what that
tells us the first component is the
first row of Q transpose which is Q 1
transpose with X yeah so that's the idea
so that's the idea here
that's the reason for our nolde and lan
shows being famous is that they figured
out a good way to orthogonalize that
basis yeah yeah do we want to see what
they did or just those would be in the
notes it's a well how do you do it so
this is the basis this is our not good
basis and then our good basis is going
to be Q's so I'll take B to be Q 1 will
be what what would be the right choice
for Q 1 well I'll take the first vector
and normalize it but it just we're just
doing gram-schmidt what would q to be
how would I find Q 2 following the
gram-schmidt idea
I take a B I subtract off its component
in this q1 direction and I normalize and
all they are no Leland shows algorithm
is is that same gram-schmidt idea
applied to these Krylov vectors so so so
are know the land shows are no lease for
any matrix and LAN choices for a
symmetric matrix where you get some
special benefit so what they did is just
you could say now they just wrote down
gram-schmidt in fact probably up the
standard gram-schmidt because we this is
a case where we really don't want to
exchange columns
I don't want suddenly to be pushed into
this one I'd rather take them in order
because it just turns out right and that
that this is in the note so let me tell
you where this is this would be section
2.1 so part two of the book which is
where we are and the first section so
what is what all together is in this
first section when you look at it that
section is standard numerical linear
algebra what any course in and MIT
offers 18.3 i'm not sure of the number
330 maybe which is all all things like
this Krylov would be there are no they
land shows of course gram and schmidt
would be there that's five people who've
thought of the same thing
and so that section 2-1 summarizes what
what's in really good a lot of textbooks
and let me mention a favorite a book by
professor and and bow
or the Bible so this is maybe a moment
to tell you about two two books on
classical numerical linear algebra what
you do for matrices of order a thousand
not for matrices of order millions
that's that you have to rethink so
trophies and bow isn't called numerical
linear algebra and do you know the
authors of the Bible of of numerical
linear algebra so that's a textbook and
what I'm down we're gonna write down now
finally is 750 pages it's grown to in in
its fourth edition it's the Bible for
all numerical linear algebra people and
it's written by golem and van loans so
gene Golub was a remarkable guy he
probably didn't write more than about
eleven pages of this Charley wrote most
of it but golem was a amazing person who
traveled the world and connected people
and left behind papers to be written and
and books to be written and so that this
ghaliban loan is now in the fourth
volume and it has so much good stuff and
references that it's like the good
reference and this is the good textbook
if you were going to teach a course on
numerical linear algebra so I think
that's I've come to the point to to
finish so I'm really have finished along
with the extra attraction of the of this
different problem I finished with ax
equal B and well at least I'm now I now
move on to what to do with really
really large matrices